talk about fallout 4 as it happens I
spend a couple of hours last night I
needed like some time away from the
wasteland so I'm back to sanctuary and I
started just doing up my house i made
like a locker from my clothes and for my
weapons and the bobblehead holder which
is only up to bobbleheads it out of like
30 holders and it was nice and relaxing
i'm both of you guys have also been
putting a lot of time into digging up
your base as well yeah i am i've renamed
the game Fallout 4 happy home designer
okay I have this problem where I ruin
open-world games and so this time I as
opposed to the other open world games
that I've found ways to get distracted
in this I got really into settlement
building and I still early in the game
because I didn't get mine early i got my
pit boyish anon friday oh cool so i got
a couple days to play before I flew up
here but but yeah I finished the first
part of the you know the original main
storyline quest where you meet Preston
any death blow yeah I kill your desk log
I get your death claw and then and then
you get back up to sanctuary and then I
started transferring everything because
I'd kind of planted everything at at
rockit as opposed to sanctuary so I was
like oh now I gotta drag her thing you
gotta soak your home my listen dog meat
you're gonna be carrying a lot of stuff
so I loaded up dog me and I came back up
the sanctuary and then I started got to
work and now everyone's got it's got a
nice bit mm-hmm I've been taken down a
bunch of houses and stuff but honestly
like it's it's a really interesting I
find the settlement building really
interesting and fall out yeah when it's
when we first got her hands on a couple
of weeks ago iron was you decided to put
together a sort of a base building guide
and for a while there were kind of just
trying to figure out like what is this
for exactly it took a while I think I
started getting a grasp of what the base
buildings higher purposes and it took
about a week and a half of actually base
building and digging through the guide
and to be honest it's one of those
features where it's a lot of fun and you
can level up and waste a ton of time but
it's totally optional mmm it mostly has
to do with the high level crafting in
the game and having places to put your
cool crafting stations so you can you
know you know build a garden and then
have a spit and roast up some stuff to
make guns
adhesives mm and or use a chemistry
station to make oil so it seems like at
the higher level the bases are for fun
and then therefore high level crafting
yeah I was hailing your ads I mean I'd
like that was the big thing that I find
myself going back for been making sure i
have like purified water of course get
back there you got your you like being
able to you know instead of using
radaway which is a little bit rare seem
to me so far it's been a little bit
rarer than in previous vlog games so I
really like that you know you can just
go back and heal up in kind of take a
break I think the cooking stuff which
obsidian out of New Vegas and has
definitely been explored a lot in this
it's really good as well because like
when you're adding like making like
steaks out of death claws and mole rats
and everything like they heal you almost
as much as stems like you can real as
long as you not playing survival mode
you can read it like pound on those and
I need your help and if you cook it you
don't take the radiation hit was really
nice yeah which is a massive you know we
go on a stick like before you you take
it but it was like oh it's like limiting
one this one it limits your maximum
health rights also there's some weapons
later in the game like the syringe er
where you have craft all the ammo for
you so yeah just got that is pretty
crazy um it's funny to like when you
build a nice base you should probably
start every day in the wasteland by
taking a nice nap if you take an eight
hour nap particularly if you have a
romantic partner there hmm um you get an
XP boost it's like ten percent for the
purse oh wow I don't know how long it is
when you go out in the wastelands is
like an hour yeah 45 minutes hour or
something like that the thing I've been
doing as well as I don't know like in
previous games the worlds of you know
the capital wasteland and new vegas and
stuff are always so like scary and
intimidating and awful and after a
mission you kind of go back to somebody
and sell the stuff you don't need let me
feel a little bit more like safe when
you're in a when you're in a like a hob
town where is what i'm doing in this now
is I'm actually I'm finding sanctuary in
sanctuary like I'm i'm going out into
the world and i'm collecting more stuff
that ideally just sell and just kind of
bring in at home I like storing it like
I did that in fallout 3 and when I
ruined fallout 3 so I got to the very
first like the area of hat homes before
you even get to make a ton i found the
lay the first lady you meet where she's
like real twitchy and jumpy and I was
just like oh I don't like this lay so I
killed her and then I
over her house and and then I ended up
just I was like well I'm gonna clean up
the apocalypse and so I just took every
when I got to the supermart that was a
real problem that was a real problems
like yo see more days to clean out yeah
I was but so it's so much like that were
all I wanted to do is just like pick up
every bit of garbage and now it's even
better because now I can scavenge and
break down stuff for crafting so it's
like you know oh this house is this
ruined house well that's I'm gonna scrap
it hey exhale mandate I love scrapping
it's great and then you know you'll fill
your room with cat posters so you feel I
know exactly know those mountains heads
I've now gone on in the sitting room and
then yesterday I was putting up some
lighting in my cuz I've gone back to my
house like the house my character your
LG house yeah I put up a lights i
leveled up to 20 because i like put up a
like a rotating fan and i've been doing
so much of that stuff over there like
previous errors that all rossini of you
if you combine it with idiot savant
they're like earlier kwara so great the
less intelligent you are the more likely
you are to have a huge boost and you
start building you can get it to trigger
fairly frequent like crafting anything
you do like just random XP just happens
it's pretty pretty great so but you have
to get like yet you have to have a
little more low intelligence which I
think for me like I preferred a little
bit more so I like I kind of want to
start a second save me like I want to
play very differently twice so but of
course you know that I'll be dead before
that's that happens before I finished
two games fallout 4 apparently there's a
cuz I yesterday I spent like a good 20
minutes taking I haven't drunk any
nuka-cola cuz i remember in the previous
game it was like they were inert is it
nirn roush in oblivion and Skyrim was
that stuff that you collected it's
always a question about like collect 10
of this set it to this vendor for like
loads of money there was one in I think
for a three or maybe it was bad on new
Vegas about nuka-cola quantum and it was
not a person we're like giving him
nuka-cola was always beneficial whenever
I've like been trained never to drink it
save him so I put them all on my fridge
would like to do so meant like picking
them up in the game and they're trying
to get him it but apparently if you're
in builder mode they straight up just
stunned Oh like they stand up on the
wrong well that's a pro tip I found out
that you can you can actually like I
went around in fifth this again like
guys I have a real
I'm a real open or gaming problem I
spent like three hours on Sunday night
just walking around fixing fences oh
thanks Ari I was like oh man these
fences I gotta fix I don't like looking
at them there's some of the fences are
down some of them are up so then but if
you're in builder moded they all snap
together really nicely doors snap in
room everything snaps in really great
and I'm like offices this is gonna be
good yeah the one no broken windows
inside as long as you start with the
foundation block that's the one trick is
like you cannot build on Hills very well
unless you put in the foundation
concrete blocks and they will level your
base out and tell me the bet about the
advanced offensive because I know you've
dipped into that iron so defenses are
kind of funny I put a lot of defenses up
initially and then my base never got
attacked yeah I couldn't fair what was
happening so it says that if you read
through the guide it says that the
higher your defense rating the less
likely you are to be attacking rise so
you may not you may never be attacked if
your defense rating is really hot
interesting and also i haven't seen
people wander into the confines of the
bases so i think they'll only start
attacking small settlements or
settlements that you've built to the
outskirts up right and they'll aggro on
things they can do yeah yeah so my my
impression of that was you just put up a
couple defenses as long as your rating
is as high as your population or higher
hmm it's not likely it'll ever happen
did you put in some of that crazy stuff
with the terminals and the lazy yeah so
at high level there's some fun stuff you
got to get a couple of the perks going
but so in order to do an advanced trap
you have to build a laser trip wire and
you hook that up to like a flamethrower
and then all that has to be hooked up to
power and a terminal okay and you tell
the terminal don't kill people I love or
like people will just walk this a fine
Carla walks through you gotta make sure
if the flavors are get turned out but
again later I nobody's attacked my base
really so I don't it's kind of a bummer
yeah like you kind of you cuz people
really build up those defenses they're
hoping people come attack them right
like that's the thing you want you're
like oh man I want to see all these
crazy home alone traps go on when the
Raiders come and then like they just
never show up maybe shoulda bummer maybe
like that yeah just do it home alone
sigh like build a really weak base yeah
with like one person in a Brahmin and
then like up with defense then just to
see what happens that seems like it
would be really fun come back and
collect the corpses
I say maybe can pull a walking dead and
like kite a bunch of raiders all the way
to a base like could you do it may be a
few kite stuff maybe you could you could
test it out and lastly guys obviously
put so much time into your various bases
what is a favorite thing you've gotten
your base right now what is your pride
and joy in your base Aaron Samson watch
if I pride and joy I you know it's it
was just building hi like I'm still
going okay I got to about four stories
and I thought that was the limit but
then i was reading through the guide and
i saw a light house with like it was
alright somebody put they had like a six
or seven or eight story structure so my
goal right now is just to build a
medieval tower as high as possible nice
i haven't done it yet but it's gonna
happen squad by joe yeah that's really
nice genie that's what you'd is all you
built yeah this there's there's no
physics like you won't fall over if it's
not properly but restore something else
who needs physics thick euless what
about yourself action uh for me i am
it's early so i feel like i'm gonna have
new favorites cuz I'm early in but I
think for right now I like is it really
dumb if I say like I'm really impressed
with my fence rebuilding no that's all
right I actually like I really like
having nice organized stuff so it's been
great to actually reorganize all of the
different yards and it's I'm like I said
if he knows everyone I ever wanted and
watching this is probably like this
broad needs a straitjacket like finer
one in the wasteland but yeah I really
like and also I I'm really proud of the
fact that really really early i was able
to build out the what is it the the
signal that brings in oh yeah people
don't signal signal beacons where people
can come in and stuff and and I I'm
really i think my favorite thing of just
settlement building actually is the
really nice quest line that I've been
doing with President going out to the
other settlements isn't really good it's
enjoyable let's go I'm happy with my
little trunk full of grog knock the
Barbarian all my magazines and stuff
just hidden eyes there I'm waiting for
someone to steal it in your fridge
nuka-cola I'm a fridge in nuka-cola but
I have to order Oregon did you write
your name on it by the way cuz those
settlers you can write your name on so I
mean like I'm just saying those settlers
might see it oh yeah thank you again
yeah I keep going into that is like
trash on Carla or someone
sit down I like it supposedly they can
pick stuff up if you just leave so yeah
they can pick and pick it up haha so be
careful all right I got a little got
game up against the posted man defense
system flamethrowers yes exactly then
tell it to shoot for anybody especially
anyone touching my nuka-cola Aaron
actually thank you so much for coming on
let us know what you think of the base
building of 404 have you built any cool
little base yourself leave your thoughts
in the comments below we'll be back in
the second folks